Chris and Marishka I tell you yes they
got this on and off will they won't they
romance going if you had to weigh in
would you want to see the two characters
get together
I'll see why not I thought it was kind
of odd early because Chris was married
you know but then then
um Chris's wife died
and uh I don't I don't I don't know
maybe I think they'd rather let that
hang on and so like a thrill in the
chase
it to some people
it's not to you though I do not see you
I mean you know it's very interesting
how they twist the plots and they make
people stay intrigued in what's going on
next you know so nothing but love to the
to the writers of this and how they make
it happen you know it I mean one season
I came back and they say you're getting
married I'm like The Who and they go the
girl you knew three seasons ago I'm like
when did that happen they said over
covet I like the fans knew that yeah and
so they they started with this plot of
me getting married and then it turned
into an engagement then it turns into us
having a ceremony where we didn't get
married so they're writing this stuff on
the Fly
yeah yeah you guys are just delivering
you wrote you got to you know my
hairstylist Jamina obsessed with the
shows like I mean I am as well but I
mean she is a die-hard through and
through on order fans so she said she
wanted to say thank you you know I
honestly it's the first show I ever
worked on what people thanked me and uh
I think that SVU especially is part show
and it's Parts therapy to a lot of
people so it has another level of
importance than the normal show does I
didn't know that when I first got on the
show but now I realize talking to women
that the show matters to them on another
level so that's good to be part of that
20 24 seasons how long can this show run
I'm hoping every year I just hope for
the next season you know so can we get
the nice 25 you know a nice quarter I
think so I think we still got momentum I
think people are still digging it
um
I I came on the show for four episodes
so this is a ride and I never expected
to be on I mean four episodes times
what I don't even know how many I'll
roll out each season
um I know we're way over 500. we do 22
to 23 a season yes ma'am what an
incredible blessing and you are blessing
the fans with the ultimate event to kick
off this season I mean this is like
one could say this is a movie it is a
movie yeah all three of the different
divisions are coming together for one
three-hour night yes
trafficking if what you're saying is
true it's beyond comprehension looks
like we're going for a ride we need to
win there's more in the story they're
building up to something we keep
fighting together what are we looking
forward to what case is going to bring
the three units together
I'm pretty sure it has I think the case
um has to do with um
an organized crime situation and it
bleeds over into us and it bleeds over
into the other thing you think of it as
like the way we shot it we shot it so
out of sequence I'll be just as excited
to see this show because I didn't read
all three scripts so I only read the SVU
part so it's very complicated like
people are like What's it gonna be and
I'm like I don't know till I see it
because I'm only in the scenes I'm in
right but I know it's a lot of
excitement it's a lot of action it's a
lot of it's a lot of everything it's
they did it like a movie